okay uh i i want to talk about um
sort of a broader issue that is going to
be facing the united states
um for many years to come and i'm glad
that more people
are talking about there's more
discussions there's more articles
talking about the reality
that there is a far bigger problem than
donald trump and that the problem
is the republican party and republican
voters and trump-ism and i've been
teasing that this is something we're
going to have to deal with for a while
this is something
we've already been talking about for
some time in our discussions about how
before the election i was saying win or
lose there will still be more than 70
million
well we thought it might only be 60
something million it turns out there
will be
72 million trumpists in the country
even when trump is gone and we have to
understand
why they are the bigger problem than
donald trump and
you can sort of think about it this way
without a president trump or a candidate
trump back in 2015-2016
the american right-wing would still be
riddled with all of the bad ideas and
xenophobia and delusions that they are
today
trumpism would still exist we just
wouldn't be calling it trumpism
without republican voters willing to
elect
trump a candidate like donald trump
would never
have gotten anywhere and case in point
if donald trump had run in the
democratic primary
he would have had no shot of winning
that primary because democratic voters
would never fall for something like
donald trump
but the republican voter did fall for it
and anne applebaum did a very
interesting interview on ezra klein's
podcast which you can find online
where they talk about this in some
detail and what ann
applebaum and ezra klein discuss
is the reality that trump is the less
interesting figure historically but that
the ease
and speed with which the republican
party including its top elected
officials
just bowed down to donald trump is what
really should scare us about the future
of the country
we talked about the rare exceptions you
know mitt romney
the late john mccain some others who are
and were republicans but they didn't
approve of donald trump's brand of
politics
but these people were few and far
between and a number of different things
came together at the exact right time
to sort of propel trump to power and
ultimately have the entire party wrapped
around his finger
trump is someone who at many other times
in american history
would not have been able to win a
republican primary
but you had a sort of perfect storm you
had a republican party that essentially
stopped having a platform in the sense
that okay they came to they claim to be
about small government
but their platform on many issues is
just do nothing just oppose what
democrats want to do
democrats the party of doing stuff
republicans increasingly the party of
not doing stuff
as a platform you then combine that with
this
reflexive rejection of barack obama
partially motivated by racism part of it
motivated by the fact that he
was a half-black president and then part
of it motivated by
you know irrational smears of so-called
socialism and communism
and you add to that what is a
fundamentally
authoritarian friendly political
movement that is the american right it's
authoritarian friendly they are fine
with authoritarianism as long as it's
their authoritarianism as long as it's
about being authoritarian
towards immigrants or gay people or
those looking for abortions or countries
that believe themselves to be on equal
footing with the united states and have
a valid opinion
as valid as that of the united states
they're fine with authoritarianism
towards that and when we look at the
republican movement for so-called
freedom and liberty over the last many
years what they're really talking about
is freedom for the big and powerful or
whoever has the guns
right you pick your version of it to do
whatever they want to the small
and weak whoever doesn't have the guns
to the s-hole countries to whoever okay
and this is reflected in some policy
but it primarily it's been reflected in
the desire
for the right to just get in the way of
government doing anything
under the guise of saying when the
government does things
it's socialism it's communism it's
marxism
and you had a two-step radicalization
that donald trump created
and benefited from and this is an
important point to understand
trump was both the cause of and the
beneficiary of
the radicalization of the republican
party step one
was trump correctly identified or his
advisors did or stephen miller right
it was identified by the trump campaign
that
his completely bogus vapid rhetoric
which wasn't even really
about anything specific um would
appeal to a large group of republicans
he can say things he'll do he can say he
will do things that of course he never
did
health care the wall fixing trade paying
off the debt so there were some
allusions to policy but you had
a group that fell for the idea of trump
as a solution to the problems they
wrongly believe exist
now remember that as the republican
voter was falling for donald trump
the establishment republicans and some
right-wing media like fox news
they resisted they initially resisted
and you go back and you look at
the things ted cruz said about donald
trump the things marco rubio
rand paul lindsey graham the things they
said about donald trump initially
they were resisting the notion that
trump was the solution the republican
voter was bamboozled first
but then step two was when the
republican voter fell for trump
the establishment republican party fell
almost completely in line with donald
trump i know there are a few exceptions
but
when the media fell in line and when
republican elected officials fell in
line
it emboldened trump it legitimized
trumpism
as a republican platform even though it
is quite literally not a platform
it was about undoing what barack obama
did
it was about angering the left
triggering the libs as they like to say
so now we are left with this crisis
beyond donald trump and hopefully now
it's clear
why it doesn't get solved by trump
leaving because most of it doesn't
actually have to do with donald trump
trump was the useful idiot at the right
time to take advantage of it
then trump subsequently made republican
elected officials and right-wing media
useful idiots for his successful
bamboozling of the republican voter
and it doesn't get solved with trump
leaving so this is now laying out the
problem
the next step is starting to think about
solutions how do you massively deprogram
72 million cultists and we're going to
continue talking about that if you have
thoughts about the solution part of it
or if you disagree with my assessment of
the problem let me know i'm on twitter
at deepakman if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps called
blinkist blinkist lets you consume an
entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks
a month and you get the entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video